[Applause]
hello everyone Nikhil children was about
to fall the simultaneous exhibition for
12 players in the crowd there was a
little boy who also wanted to take part
in the simultaneous exhibition but the
organizers said there just isn't enough
room for him to play they only have 12
boards set up and sugar and said doesn't
matter why he said like in the other
room set up one table for him and I will
play against in blindfold when I get to
his position and so they did they set up
the position and this is the game
default e4 e5 Knight f3 knight c6 Bishop
c4 we should c5 c3 Knight of 6 d 4 d 6b
4b 34 position before check Knight c3
and the Knight takes e4 the famous the
beginning of the famous Greco attack
here White Castle I forgot to mention as
you were in plain white as he is playing
white on board it is a simultaneous
exhibition nice captures on t3b text III
and Bishop takes c3 attacking the rook
will be 3 and here this is the Greco's
detect in the forest and here white wins
in all in all life and the kids took the
route the children play Bishop takes f7
check King to FX and Bishop g5 and here
the little kid plays Knight takes d4 and
the cheering was overwhelmed he didn't
know what to do
she did play this game against
Louisville kid blindfolded and it was
simultaneous exhibition and she was
walked here he's down the rook his queen
is attacked if he hits the black queen
the knighthood will take his queen and
he was overwhelmed he he thought this
little kid destroyed a 400 year old the
chest theory you know whenever you hear
records attack you know record detector
which stands the test of time every time
it was a challenge and in this position
I can't really remember what you going
played I read this in one book I have
traps in the openings children
continuing the game and a couple of
moves later the little kid made a
mistake and blundered the game so she
wouldn't want the games but after the
game children asked the kid like kid you
know do you have any idea what you have
done
the kids like nobody what he said you go
you found the novelty you destroy the
400 year old chest theory and a little
kids test again I don't know I know I
don't know much about chest theory
Grandmaster but I do know that when age
3 gives check and after black defends
against this check for example d6 or
maybe c5 or any other move white ink
recaptures black screen and it game over
so children was playing this game
blindfolded and he made this simple
queen a3 and he thought wow this little
kid did something no one else thought of
so amazing
so even though sugaring won the game he
was very sad that no novelties were
discovered in this line of the greco
attack thank you for watching and see
you soon